faut-il déjà parlé d'une énième réforme
des rythmes scolaires
sur le papier le nouveau projet de
décret prévoit en réalité de donner plus
de liberté aux communes aménagement des
horaires et donc éventuel retour à la
semaine de quatre jours
le décret pourrait s'appliquer dès la
rentrée prochaine dans certaines
communes les enseignants eux réclament
plus de temps au niveau des écoles
rebondir pour la rentrée prochaine sur
un nouveau rythme c'est illusoire et
compliqué à organiser le retour à 4
jours ou 4 go reste à quatre jours et
demi
les enseignants sont prêts à rediscuter
de cela ce qui est important c'est quand
même qu'ils aient le temps de mettre en
place une stratégie de concertation et
que quand même on s'intéresse l
équilibre de vie pour l'élève dans le
cadre de ces apprentissages à tour
impossible de faire machine arrière dès
septembre prochain
outre la réorganisation du temps de
travail des neuf mille quatre cents
enfants scolarisés des emplois notamment
des intervenants tape seraient également
menacés on travaille avec quatre
opérateurs sur la ville de tournai dans
un cadre de marchés publics
et donc voilà on ne peut pas résilié
comme ça du jour au lendemain sachant
qu'il ya quand même énormément d'emplois
à la clef et puis on a quand même 300
animateurs par jour qui travaillent pour
l'état paie donc ça veut dire faire des
conséquences aussi pour ça pour ces
personnes
enfin pour certaines plus petites
communes le nouveau décret même s'il
serait peut être plus bénéfique à l
équilibre de l'enfant pourrait néanmoins
par ricochet conduire à détricoter les
activités périscolaires que les
municipalités ont souvent mis beaucoup
de temps à mettre en place
pour ma part je serai partisane de ne
rien toucher les l'été ap marche bien
chez nous je pense qu'il est raisonnable
de ne pas modifier trop de choses dans
la hâte
on est à peu près tranquille sur les
financements de l'état pour 2017 et 2018
attendons cette année 2017 2018 et
mettant là à profit pour discuter et
organiser la rentrée 2010 8 s'il doit y
avoir des modifications
le décret a été présenté aujourd'hui à
la communauté éducative
les communes devraient avoir jusqu'en
offre pour soumettre leur choix